foreign
[Music]
to discuss the by-election results on
The Spectators political editor Katie
balls and pollster James Johnson from
jlp Partners Katie what's the reaction
in Westminster to the results I think
it's quite a mixed bag if you look at
the results in the sense that
the Tories have not done well
um if you look at the fact they've lost
salvi formerly seen as to resave seat
majority over 20 000 to labor summiting
and through and they've also lost to the
lib Dems I think that was more expected
when it was first called because we know
the lib Dems had done successfully well
in recent by-elections over the past
couple of years
um but you put the two together and it
looks as though the Tories are on course
to lose power at the next election
should nothing change but then I think a
small ray of light and perhaps it's
giving false assurances but
certainly in terms of how rich you see
neck handles today in the coming weeks
there's a ray of light in the fact they
kept hold of Oxbridge and therefore you
had a situation whereby
um only only by a small amount about 500
votes in it just under
um which allowed the tourists to keep it
and to prevent uh laid from taking it
but that has just disrupted I think
quite a bit in a narrative so yes Tori's
doing badly and but it's not that triple
by-election loss which I think was
widely predicted when I spoke to people
in labor also the Tory party all were
saying that was likely to happen and
therefore you now have quite a
interesting situation where labor seemed
to be having an internal fight about
wrong and Uxbridge and as things stand
and of course we're talking
mid-afternoon
um today on a Friday afternoon but as
insan there was actually little sign of
Tories lashing in it and which is
probably what we would expected more of
if you said you know watching it's going
to happen and those these results come
through and instead you seem to have a
rule of words between the London labor
party and
really putting quite a lot of the blame
on Sadiq Khan saying you less ultra low
emission zones were unpopular
um and the mayor needs to reflect on
that as do the leadership and which I
think is
um not only attracting more attention to
the Rao when they had a pretty good
result in Selby and but it was also
sowing seeds of discontent for the
future
um and James that point about the sort
of uh expectations in Westminster is
really key I think the conservatives
probably expected uh to lose all three
of these what are the sort of polling
lessons from looking at the results from
last night
yeah well the uh the conservatives will
be will be pleased with that Oxford
result even though in the way that these
things work it was only a very small
margin if that margin had been the other
way then today's reaction would be would
be very different
um we ran at jail Partners two polls uh
a couple of weeks before the
buy-elections um in Selby and agency
um uh we got the uh the labor margin
spot on at 12 points ahead
um very very large swing uh for labor
there
um in Oxbridge we had labor ahead by
eight points um but we did say that
there was a big chunk of undecided
voters who are leaning conservative and
Euless there was a very Salient issue
and it was conservative owned clearly in
the last couple of weeks of the campaign
the conservatives were able to squeeze
some of the votes whether from the
independence from the reclaim party from
others and really uh make that
anti-ula's argument and still seal the
deal and obviously in Summerton of room
less polling there I don't think any
poll actually took place there but
clearly that abdem's continuing their
pattern
um of doing very well in conservative
facing by-election so broadly speaking a
pretty uh a pretty good night um for the
polls uh that that took place
um and it does show that ability
um for the conservatives to mobilize
opinion around a local issue how much
help that will be in a general election
of course is rather another question
yeah I mean Katie that's the real big
reaction here there's some conservative
MPS I've been talking to who said well
there's an issue across the country but
they're frankly don't seem to be that
many issues and which you can kind of
get the motivating turnout and beat
labor on yeah I think there's a few ways
of looking at it so I think one of the
um consequences of the result in
Oxbridge is both parties are now going
to start to have a big debate about
green issues and what your position
should be and how you cover it and for
labor we know that they've been having
quite a difficult green debate uh anyway
uh if we think back to the last Labor
conference where they were very close to
taking what was the Red Rose uh the
labor logo and just making it a green
Rose to make the point that it was you
know they were an environmental party we
feel so far away from that now
um yes Ed Miller Band is still pushing
for the the green agenda but the 28
billion has been watered down and you
think even though this isn't technically
uh you know a net zero it's more about
air pollution it is just feeding into
that narrative if so you're speaking to
figures in labor today and I'm saying
but it's another reason we have to be
really cautious and we need to not be
having particularly bold policies and I
think you're going to see more when it
comes to you know how big do they would
go on Green in their pitch and more of
the argument of economy first gree has
to come after then for the Tory side I
think as you touch on there's going to
be a temptation to think well ooh
there's worked for us here
um can we bring that out to a national
level and if you think about also
recently for example the campaign by the
mail about um the current electric car
targets and saying we need to delay this
the country's not ready I think after
today's results and of course uh the
cover of The Spectator this week is on
the war on motorist too but I think
people are going to start to think that
these issues are even more potent and
what do the Tories have to say over
labor something I wrote about recently
is that um it's quite if you think about
shaping the labor debate on green GMB
the union is actually pushing for this
quite um you know skeptical about green
jobs and that's not a factor but how do
the Tories respond do they try and get
ahead trying to repeat and then I think
the other thing to know about that
Uxbridge result is
you could say oh it's all about this one
issue I don't think people ever vote
just about one issue
but it clearly helped
um when it came to working out what the
campaign was what your message was
um and then I think that if you're I
suppose if you were being Optimist in
government right now you would look at
the axbridge result and think well this
was about actually thinking what a labor
government would do this this time in
the form of the London labor mayor and
and therefore as you get closer to an
election voters are going to have much
more of a sense and much more in their
mind as to not just oh I'm fed up with
the Tories they're useless but
effectively what does that what do the
other guys bring me and therefore there
are potentially opportunities for the
Tories to say it brings you this it's
going to do this to your mortgage rates
now because the labor are going to turn
around and say your mortgage rates are
high on the first place because of the
Tories but I actually but I do think um
it'll be easier to kind of get to that
choice of crystallizing where you look
at the other two and there's definitely
an anti-tory though I just think the
closer you get to an election they'll be
the vote of but what am I voting for if
I do go for the other side so James what
strategy should the conservatives really
be embracing and taking the lessons from
here I mean should they be looking at
Net Zero skepticism as some like Richard
Tyson reform have been advocating or
should they really be trying to
concentrate minds and turn that sort of
prospect of a hypothetical labor
government into one that kind of scares
voters and makes up Minds as it comes to
polling day
yeah I think the conservatives need to
be cautious about reading too much into
the the green side of things here
um unlike in the US UK voters are very
consensus driven on their view of uh the
environment they care a lot about the
environment they want to see measures to
help it and they're obviously cautious
uh when it comes to things that uh
really sort of whack them um in terms of
costs like Euless but broadly speaking
um there would be an aversion I think to
the conservatives going too hard on sort
of green bashing amongst some of those
uh key swing voters I think what it does
tell us um touching on Katie's point
there is that the conservatives were
able to coalesce around an issue and be
quite disciplined about talking about it
and focusing on it now Euless is quite a
local issue so that's probably not going
to have quite as much sway when it comes
to a general election
um but there are certainly other issues
that feed into hesitations that people
have about Labor such as immigration
such as some of the cultural issues such
as their record on the economy
um the conservatives would be able to
weaponize RC by seat basis at the next
election if we go back to that Selby
poll that I mentioned I mentioned that
in Oxbridge Euless was the conservative
owned issue of mossalian in Selby there
was also only one issue which the
conservatives had a lead on and was also
Salient and that was immigration now you
didn't see the conservatives going hard
on that in the local campaign in the
by-election but if you could see you
know a general election in seats like
Selby
um the conservatives going really hard
on something like the immigration
whether it's a legal immigration small
boats or legal immigration numbers and
what a labor government would like on
that you could see there being a real
benefit so I think the main lesson from
the conservatives here is well firstly
you're still in trouble guys this was
not a good result they you know clung
onto Uxbridge by the cling of their uh
by the uh by the Skin of Their Teeth
um and secondly to turn that around
you've got to get Punchy you've got to
find these strong issues that you can
link to the National story for a general
election but you can also use to expose
labors weaknesses or an individual seat
level
we've talked about Uxbridge we've talked
about Selby
um Katie finally probably the most
unsurprised result of the night was that
the lib Dems did their usual thing from
very well in a by-election and took
Simonson and Froome
um how wide are conservative MPS right
now because lib Dems always do well in
by-elections but as James was saying
there Nationals are very different and
trying to fight local issues as National
ones can bring you into problems yeah so
I think has mixed opinion in the Tory
party as to how grave of threat the
liberal Democrats pose
um some points you know previous
by-election so the liberal Democrats
have come in and then at the general
election it's been the conservative kept
the seat
um but then I remember speaking to a few
red wool MPS recently and they said and
perhaps they would want to say this but
they said they'd rather have their seats
in the majority around ten thousand and
have a 20 000 majority in the South
because of the lib Dems and the greens
and they thought that was actually
harder to battle as your adversary than
going straight against labor which well
they think the the voters soft and it
will go down near an election partly for
some of the reasons that Jay was just
outlined in terms of how you might
attack labor and so I think particularly
after local elections there is concern I
think
what the liberal Democrats has done has
done wrong in the past is they get some
luck and some wind in their sales
um through by-elections local elections
and then they aim a bit too high and
going for lots of seats of course we all
remember Joe Swinson telling us she
could be the next prime minister and
losing her seat yeah exactly didn't
quite work out and I mean that's an
extreme level
um but even if you take that one to one
side often they will just aim for a high
number of seats and therefore you spread
out your resources so I think there's
going to be a tricky calculation for Ed
Davey I mean he's looking at all these
successes and certainly the South West
is an area along with the blue wall
where the level of Democrats think they
are you know fighting fit for the next
election but working out what how many
are really going to seriously Target
um where I think it's probably tempting
to go for a very high number but history
does suggest
um that they should stay pretty focused
and then they could get some good
results but it's never usually as good
as it seems to live Dems James how many
should the liblands be looking at here I
mean last time they suggested they could
somehow end up running the country's
prime minister I mean is that we're
talking a dozen here two dozen a
whereabouts would they be in the
southwest Southeast in the country
yeah it's certainly in those in those
Southern seats I think you know
Southwestern seats that um they held uh
before
um 2015 you could you could see some
inroads certainly seats around London
like Eastern Walton
um as well as a couple of those London
ones as well you'd expect to be
vulnerable I am a little skeptical about
the extent of a lib 10 performance in a
general election
um they've done very very well in these
bad actions getting consistent swings in
the high 20s but they are very local
issues with very little implications for
who runs the government
um and uh suit that have Dems you know
in terms of places where they can run a
strong ground game and mobilize opinion
when that becomes about National issues
about who's going to run the government
who's going to run the economy labor and
the conservatives will be looking to
squeeze that lib Dem boat out uh and I
um and also even in seats where it's a
Tory lib Dem marginal unless there's
some kind of informal Pax between lib
Dems and labor you would expect labor to
still get some votes in those seats for
people who don't know much about
tactical voting or don't know that you
know that they even elect an MP you know
a lot of people still assume that the
electoral system is just 34 nationally
and and the party that gets the most
votes overall than the country wins so
um there is a uh there are limitations I
think on what the lib demons can do come
a general election uh if things stay as
they are now I'd expect them to be in
that sort of two dozen seats range which
would be very bad for the conservatives
um if the conservatives can can narrow
the Gap a little bit don't think it's
implausible that you know they could end
up posted to sort of 12 to 15 seats
which would which would not be very good
for them at all thank you James thank
you Katie and thank you for watching
spectator TV
[Music]
thank you